all right I think one of the reasons I'm
here today is because I've been using
our for a really long time since version
0.65 and so anyway that's my only that's
my only real credential so there's that
too I guess yeah but my actual employer
doesn't like me saying that they like me
saying that I work at the Department of
biostatistics of Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School to look Public Health and this is
the picture of it right here so I I'm a
professor here and biostatistics as
Jared mentioned I also have a podcast
with Hilary Parker who's the data
scientist at stitch fix it's called not
so standard deviations and and I teach a
few courses online and so I struggled
kind of a little bit to about what to
talk about here and I thought I would
just look I would just talk about kind
of what it is I do
and so the motto of our school in the
school Public Health this you know the
School of Medicine they save lives
one at a time right but but we protect
health save lives millions at a time
this is our model and I just add a
little insertion there so so I do a lot
of work in environmental health I want
to talk a little bit about how it kind
of we do that and how it's done how it's
different from what it used to be in
turn and how it is what it is now so if
I were to just so kind of one slide
about kind of the improvement and in
kind of air pollution and the
environment over the course of the last
20 years I can show you this slide here
so this is the average particulate
matter levels in all the 50 states
well 51 include Washington DC over the
past roughly 18 years and you can see
there's about a 40% drop on average in
air pollution levels across the country
and this is not by accident it's not
because we all felt good about is
because of an increasingly stringent
regulation of kind of air pollution in
the air in in our in our environment a
similar picture this is the level of
sulfate that's kind of over the last 20
or so years part of this decrease is due
to the acid rain program which is an
edge
part of the kind of East Coast
management of sulfates so there's been
dramatic improvement in pollution over
time and that's had a major benefit for
Public Health and so I want to show you
this picture this picture is arguably
the basis of almost all air pollution
regulation in the United States it is
from the six cities study and you can
see there's a correlation there on the x
axis you have the average kind of
particle level in each of these six
cities there's names of which I don't
remember because they're all kind of
cities in the Midwest where I don't live
the y-axis is the mortality rate okay so
as pollution goes up portal your rate
goes up and if you compare the most
polluted to the least polluted city
there's a 26% increase in mortality
which is unheard of really in any kind
of environmental application another
picture that is kind of a summary of how
air pollution research got started is
this one this is a London Fog in 1952 so
on the left hand side on the that black
line is the level of total particles or
it's called black smoke and and it's
about one point five milligrams per
meter cubed so just in case you're
wondering we don't measure pollution and
milligrams per meter cubed I'm aware
it's too big of a unit we measure in
micrograms per meter cube so but back
then they measured in milligrams and
it's that so it's like 1,500 micrograms
per meter cube
naturally ambient air quality standard
in the United States is 35 so things
were much worse back in the 50s now you
can see that the lettin the number of
deaths spiked up I mean almost
immediately after the pollution went up
and there are estimates that were about
10,000 excess deaths just in this
two-week period so this is kind of this
spurt a lot of the research and kind of
policy making in air pollution health so
what does an air pollution study look
like basically here's a lovely picture
of Beijing China I hope I don't know if
anyone's been there but it's a great
city it's a great city when it looks
like this it's not so great when it
looks like that and the basis of all air
pollution or basically every air
pollution in this study is we get a
bunch of people and we say can we follow
you on days that look like this and on
days that look like that and see what
happens to your health on both of those
days all right so these are both in the
same city we can also say get
a bunch of people who live in Beijing
recruit thousands of people in this city
and compare them to people who live in
lovely Chicago where it's quite a bit
cleaner so those those are roughly the
kind of two kinds of studies there's
temporal studies and there's
cross-sectional studies where we look
across the base and so a problem with
this kind of old way of doing things so
the six cities study that I mentioned
earlier had 8,000 people enrolled they
enrolled in night it took 20 years to do
that study they mostly enrolled in 1970
in their early mid 70s and the paper was
published in 1993 so you know it's very
expensive it's very time-consuming it's
very resource intensive to do that and
so it's hard and harder to do that these
days because it's not as much money
running around so what do most air
pollution studies look like today they
basically look like that with a little
bit of are thrown in so there's a lot of
stuff that you can do now just sitting
in my office with a computer and a lot
of our so I want to talk about little
bit kind of how that's done and what's
involved so the the prints of the
premise here is that the old way was
hard and expensive and this new way with
puppets and computers is easy and cheap
right so especially if the puppets doing
all the work so all right so if there
were a licensing exam for doing air
pollution and health research there
would only be one question on it and it
would be can you navigate the EPA
website
because basically whatever every
pollution study starts here at the air
quality system website and you just
start clicking randomly until you get to
the this site just and you know it's not
gonna be the same link every time so
just keep just keep clicking and now so
this each one these are different gases
you got ozone you got your sulfur
dioxide carbon monoxide no2 and each row
of this table is a year's worth of data
which ends each file has all of the data
from all of the monitors for that gas
across the entire country for that year
I don't care about gases though I care
about particles and so these are all the
particle data and what the file that I'm
interested in is this one here so this
is this single file has all of the 2018
that's when it's not finished yet but
all the 2018 data for every monitor in
the country on a daily basis so daily is
a 24-hour average measurements now I
don't want it's just a single years
where the data I want all the years
right and so I got to get all of these
files and so that's where my for loop
comes into play and I just want you to
know that this for loop only works if
you indent eight spaces so just so you
know those of you with your I've see I
see the your four and two space in dents
out there and I don't even know how that
code runs
so um so I'm going through them
downloading all these files these zip
files and now I got to read these zip
file so I can just read directly from
the zip file but it's kind of convenient
of course as soon as I run this code it
doesn't work and I'm screaming because
of course I forgot to load the package
and so now I'm now gonna load the
package and it will work and this is the
typical file this is this is the typical
air pollution data I think this is for
2017 and and there's a lot of variables
here this loot longitude -87 I'm
guessing that's like Alabama latitude 30
and so the variables I'm particularly
interested in here are the arithmetic
mean so that's the kind of like the
sample mean not the sample me it's the
the mean of pollution for our given day
it's a 24-hour mean I want to know where
this monitor is so there's a state code
County County code and a site number and
so state code 1 they are there in
alphabetical order and so I think it's
Alabama so that's that's that's that's
where we start and this is for only a
single year and I want to kind of put
all this data together and so there's a
number of I need to know the date of
course - number of group by summarizes
later we can produce something that
looks like this so this is from this is
particulate matter data from the fine
city or the Cook County which includes
Chicago this for 2008 and 2010 above so
three years of data you can see I put a
dashed line or the National ambient air
quality standard is since 2008 and you
can see Chicago is a not the worst
offender but not exactly the best that
was staying below the standard this is
just Los Angeles County same exact data
particulate matter data from since 2008
and you can see that there they often
greatly exceed the standard and so so
this is kind of the data that we can
produce from downloading all those files
in the EPA website assuming we finally
figure out which link to click on so
okay so we're one third of the way there
we've got our air pollution data we've
kind of a grated it all together and we
produce a really nice time series so
we're doing air pollution and health
studies so we've got the first part we
need the second part we need the health
data right so
we get our health data from two large
national insurance programs called
Medicaid and Medicare these are all
insurance claims so we have information
about people's hospitalizations
emergency department visits doctor's
visits prescription drugs and these data
are surprisingly clean part of the
reason is because we pay about $50,000
to resdac for them to give us the data
and they do a lot of work to clean it up
so the problem is not so much that the
data is messy the problem is actually
that the programs are messy so Medicaid
is a joint federal-state administered
health insurance program where every
state has a slightly different way of
defining who's eligible and it's just a
it's very difficult to understand
Medicare is so much simpler because it's
a uniform national system but either way
there's about 45 million people in
Medicare
as of 2010 there's 50 million people in
Medicaid but as of today it is more like
75 million people in Medicaid so that's
kind of the amount of data so B and we'd
like to look at a national level so we
looked ended grab all the data at once
so first of all the first file we used
to deal with is the personnel file right
so this is the file that has all the
individual level information that we
have where everyone enrolled in Medicare
or make oh this is for Medicaid but
they're very similar so this file has
668 variables and this is someone medet
and the metadata for it and we need to
choose which variables we want we don't
want all of them and the files too big
to kind of grab all the data so I don't
even run this through our I just use the
cout function the cut command in the
UNIX so just grab the the columns that I
need and to spit out a much smaller file
that I just read into our sum so once
I've cut all these personal data files I
get a master list of ID's so these are
the encrypted IDs for all the subjects
in Medicaid just and I'm in this
particular study that I was doing is
we're only looking at children so
they're about 25 million children and
Medicaid that were eligible for this
study with this information we have some
demographic information they're aged
self-reported gender race county and zip
code of residence and how and their
eligibility status for met for Medicaid
so so that's kind of on the one hand on
the other hand we need to know what
their healthcare utilization is like so
they go to the hospital then they go to
the doctor and and we know that because
all the hospitals and doctors bill
Medicaid for reimbursement and so when
we get that bill it comes through we
have that information and so we can
gather all that so for example in this
case I'm looking I'm interested in
asthma cases
so that's icd-9 code 493 so i'm grepping
all of the instances of 493 in the in
the in this case is the other therapy
file which is the basically the
outpatient file i'm grep it now i'm
using perl equals true otherwise it
takes forever and I'm grabbing it so now
I have all of my cases here this is just
for one state and how many times they
went to the doctor how many times they
went to the ER I also have hospital
admissions too so I've got my
demographic information on the one hand
I've got my case information on the
other hand you know what's coming it's
gonna be a join right so I can join that
together and now I've got a file that
has everyone's demographic information
and everyone's hospitalization
healthcare utilization information and
so and so so once I've got that file I
know where they live I had their county
and zip code of residence and so giving
my air pollution data which also has
county and zip code information I can
start linking things together all right
so we are two-thirds of the way there
there's a final third which is all of
the other stuff that's trying to make
your life difficult so we need weather
data the weather data is a huge
confounder it influences air pollution
it has a huge effect on health itself
and so we need to get weather data we
get the NL das data from NASA which is a
computer model system as gridded to a
degree across the entire country and so
we can grab these these it's up to image
files and overlay them on the on the
areas where we're looking at air
pollution and health they have to have
census data for other kind of
confounding information things like
poverty and other socio-economic status
type variables and someone mentioned
already there's 20 some packages for for
looking at census data so we use a lot
of those there we have air quality
modeling data so this is again from the
EPA this is the community multi scale
air quality modeling system they have a
computer model that simulates air
pollution
across the country and it's pretty good
for some cases and not so others but we
do incorporate them into some of our
modeling so CMAC is another input that
we use and finally we have the national
emissions inventory which has all these
sources of air pollution all the major
sources of air pollution across the
entire country and so we can at least we
don't probably there pollution that
tends to move around in the air so just
because you know where the sources
doesn't mean you know where the
pollution is but knowing where the
sources is does help quite a bit so we
have we use that information too so
having all this information together
anyone who's worked with spatial data
knows that the changes support problem
is a huge problem okay so this is
Baltimore City the boundaries of the
belt was where I live in the upper left
corner of this county so first of all we
have air monitoring data from the EPA
there were three monitors in Baltimore
City
these are point locations so and
remember our health data is aggregated
to the county level or the zip code
level alright so we imagine we have a
like a number of hospitalizations for
this for Baltimore City on a given day
but we have point level information
about air pollution monitoring we've got
our weather data which is gridded right
because this computer model output so
it's gridded to a third degree and so
we've got that and then we've got C Mac
model air pollution monitoring data
which is at a different resolution and
so it's on a different grid altogether
and so we have two separate grids we
have a point location of the monitors
and then they have this weird outline
that's called the county and so all of
that has to be kind of assimilated
together and aligned so that we can see
if things are correlated with each other
and in order to do that there's no right
way to do that you have to make
assumptions or you have to build models
to do that and all of those different
things that every time you align two
things together you introduce a new
source of uncertainty and so that's one
of the problems that we deal with all
the time all right so what do we get
when we do all that we can make maps
okay so this is a national map of fine
particulate matter that we built for the
purposes of our health studies this is
came from a paper that just came out
this year so this is every county in the
United States and that black dots are
where the monitors actually are so
that's what we have like observed
information you can see that leaves out
a lot of counties in the United States
if we only use the areas that
monitors so here's is our kind of
prediction model for particulate matter
here's a close-up of the state of
Maryland you can see Baltimore as a nice
hot spot there for pollution also in
Western Maryland where there's a lot of
coal burning stoves and also they get a
lot of pollution from our friendly
neighbors in Pennsylvania and and Ohio
and West Virginia and so this is so
that's so that's this is we can put all
this information together and build
these prediction models which they sound
fancy but it's actually just a really
large linear regression model so we can
also have these maps of the of the other
hand other side of the equation so these
are the hospitalizations for asthma and
Medicaid this has just come straight
from Medicaid there's no modeling here
and the gray areas those states have not
seceded from the Union they're just
their data is very different and so we
couldn't really include it in this study
all right so what's an air pollution
study after all this work it's just do
those is the left hand map correlated
with the right hand map is all it is and
we can look at correlation at different
spatial scales so we can look you know
for the whole country we're gonna look
at small regions and things like that so
there's all kinds of variations that we
can do but but ultimately we want to
know that the left hand side is
correlated with the right hand side and
this is on a spatial comparison we can
do temporal comparisons too so we can
see on the left hand side we have time
series of pollutants and on the right
hand side we have time series of things
like hospitalizations again we want to
know that the left hand side is
correlated or the right hand side it's
not super complicated of course we're
adjusting for all kinds of other things
in our models but this is the basic idea
all right so you like any other analysis
you might do I spent most of the talk
talking about Randol wrangling the data
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
so I'm gonna spend one slide on
statistical modeling and that's it it's
just that that's where all the time goes
I guess I should be spending all the
rest of the time complaining about the
first couple slides but um so the two
kinds of studies we do there's time
series studies where we look at acute
effects short-term effects you know on
the decourt on the order of a couple
days these are because the datasets tend
to be too big to just do all
once we do these in we always do them in
multiple stages so in the first stage we
fit a generalized linear model with a
count out come with has a pollution and
you know there's a lot of stuff in there
that couldn't fit on the screen so I
just call this stuff but a lot of
information goes into there and we do a
time sir and we do basically a
generalized linear model to look at the
short-term association between pollution
and whatever outcome we happen to be
looking at and we do this for every
county that we have information on and
then once we get risk estimates for all
those counties we combine them together
in a hierarchical model using a package
called TL knees which is a two-level
normal model and and then we get a final
kind of national level estimate for the
whole country national level estimates
aren't always the best thing to do but
they they are nice from a policy
perspective because EPA sets things like
federal policy the other kind of study
we do is a cross-sectional study where
we're comparing different areas to each
other as opposed to different times to
each other and there this first stage we
have to predict all the pollution so I
showed you those maps where we do all
the prediction so we make all the
predictions first and then we
incorporate those into semi-parametric
regression models to look at what the
health effects are of that pollution of
course we have to incorporate the
uncertainty from the prediction itself
using a kind of nonparametric bootstrap
so those are the these are the basically
the two kinds of studies that we do with
this kind of data and these are the kind
of results we can produce so this is
from a paper in 2006 we're looking at
fine particles and on the right hand
column probably ardency
we we estimate how many hospital
admissions could be prevented if we just
if we lower it air pollution by 10
micrograms per meter cubed which is it's
a lot it's asking a lot it's not like a
trivial amount but here are the various
kind of the kind of averted
hospitalizations for each of these
different cardiac and respiratory health
outcomes and if you total it all up it's
about 11,000 hospitalizations per year
which is not a trivial amount it's not
millions at a time but it it is in the
order of thousands and the fact of the
matter is that we could save 11,000
hospitalizations per year in two ways
one is we can cure all those diseases
right or we can do something that we've
been doing for the last 20 years which
is just it's just this right
so we know how to do this we don't know
how to cure all those other diseases all
right at least not yet it would be great
if we could cure those diseases we'd
save a lot more than 11-thousand right
but we already know how to do this and
so so I think so so the environment
pollution control policies have a huge
effect on health outcomes across the
country so very quickly just lessons
learned the data this kind of data will
fight you every step of the way there's
no question about that one of the things
that we started doing very early on and
this research is is investing in
hierarchical modeling because it's a
very easy a very cheap way to get around
the fact that you can't fit all the data
into our so it cuts staging things out
into separate stages allows you to kind
of kind of taking take advantage of
Independence between the data and split
things into kind of manageable parts of
course there's a price you pay which is
an increase in uncertainty but but it's
probably worth it the fact of the matter
is these data only get you so far so
it's nice to be able to work in your
office of the computer it's a lot it is
cheaper and it's a lot simpler but you
can only answer certain kinds of
questions you can't answer very subtle
questions these are very blunt questions
we're asking are you going to the
hospital we're asking or you go are you
dying these are very blunt questions and
you can't ask something more subtle with
these kinds of data it's just not
possible
so as it turns out the new way it's also
difficult it's difficult in totally
different ways than the old way and it
can be expensive too so it's not a
panacea for the old ways all right thank
you
[Applause]